karaoke bars popular across the valley
but ones that serve alcohol are off
limit to minors of course however one
county commissioner looking to change
that madison kimbrough live at 702
karaoke or on spring mountain madison
has those details
the initial proposal was discussed at
last week's county commission meeting
and tonight we hear from local karaoke
karaoke bars around town about their
thoughts on the matter
karaoke bars around vegas may soon be
changing in a recent county commission
meeting a new proposal was introduced
that would allow minors in karaoke bars
where alcohol is served county
commissioner justin jones who issued the
proposal explains i got some contacts
from some of the karaoke establishments
a lot of them are in my district because
i represent spring valley
spring mountain
area we think it should be just like any
other type of activity
we're going to put some limitations on a
number of hours that miners could be in
a karaoke place over at kamu ultra
karaoke at the venetian even though it's
not up to code they do allow miners in
their facility until 10 pm we still want
to accept the minor because like as like
a family unit they want
they can they can have a good time
together they have to bring in a dog and
also we are not allowed to serve any
alcohol into the room and here at 702
karaoke they say not allowing minors in
their karaoke rooms has actually made it
easier on them in my personal opinion
the
not allowing minors is
easier to run logistically minors
if they come in with their friends
they're trying to sneak in beverages or
stuff like that
and as a business owner you don't want
to deal with that liability
if you're under 21 and want to come to
702 karaoke they do have their
restaurant license so miners are allowed
in the dining area like you see here now
the next step for the proposal is
drafting an ordinance that of which
should be done which in this month and
then a final vote will be made in may
reporting live madison kimbrough live
local now